by one world formi formi formi
formidable
[Musique]
il est là parce qu'il va rester un quart
d'heure avec lui et c'est quand même
l'événement du jour dans toujours à mon
poste donc on arrête tout on reprendra
juste après charles aznavour et a vécu
[Applaudissements]
la nation
c'est
damphousse pas m'enfin moi notamment
sans les bocaux pas ça ils vont rentrer
dans l'émission merci charles d'être
avec nous par exemple beau bon maquiller
coiffer j'ai tout fait j'ai pris les
meilleurs coins il manquait que le
manucure et une pédicure s'arrêter bien
comment ça m'aurait plu vous voulez je
vous envoie benhaim à la maison ah oui
mais la prochaine fois je vais
boulangerie charles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il arrive le ventre
le bruit les bateaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a décidé bien sûr de rendre hommage à
charles aznavour charles aznavour qui
nous a quittés aujourd'hui à 94 ans
alors pour les plus jeunes qui nous
regardent
mais c'est vrai que charles aznavour
tout le monde le connaît middle voilà
tout le monde a une chanson de charles
aznavour dans la tête
[Musique]
charles il faut savoir que vos plus
grands fans c'est cyril et comme
regarder dire que vous aider les jeunes
chanteurs on voudrait faire un test avec
la production est pas au courant
voilà l'idée c'est que en fait je donne
des titres de vos chansons et le défi
c'est qu'il dit qu'il est capable
touchante et on va voir s'il est capable
véritablement on commence par comme ils
disent j'habite seul avec ma bande dans
un très vieil appartement aux russes
ararat que j'ai pu obtenir compagnie lui
de tortues d'eau qu'elle arrive c'est
plus joyeux que l'original mais c'est
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
m
le sang
ça aurait
on pense très fort à sa famille bien
entendu et c'est vrai qu'on voulait une
émission voilà en tout cas tout ce début
d'émission
on voulait que le consacrer à
charlesbourg on voulait une émission à
la fois avec des anedoctes à la fois
joyeuse parce que charles il était
extrêmement joyeux toujours de bonne
humeur toujours hilare il aimait il
aimait manger et les beaux arts il
aimait rigoler il était mais il était
mine de rien c'était un métronome c'est
à dire que vraiment l'été ça ça c'est un
bon tri il sortait jamais il ne s'était
pas un crs est pas un mec qui sortait
beaucoup c'est un bosseur il avait
toujours une idée dans la tête et moi
c'est ça qui m'étonnait avec lui c'est
qu'à chaque fois il avait une nouvelle
idée et voilà il et il était vraiment
formidable et je peux vous dire vraiment
moi personnellement il va me manquer et
il va manquer énormément à la france
le sort pas c'est celui qui va naître le
temps d'aimer et de disparaître
la mama et sans venus ils sont tous là
dès qu'ils ont entendu ce cri elle va
mourir à duda sans se retourner et les
master class au destin qui nous ce qui
nous des armes
charles aznavour on pense bien sûr très
fort à sa famille j'ai une très grosse
pensée pour la fille de charles aznavour
qui est vraiment une amie très proche
katia à qui je fais un énorme bisou je
pense très fort à elle est bien sûr mon
meilleur ami jean rachid voilà qui est
le voilà le demande le gendre de charles
aznavour à qui je pense très fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier encore j'avais deux râteaux je
caressais le temps et jouer de la vie
quand on joue de l'amour et je vivais là
devis sans compter sur les jours qui
fuyait dans le temps des formes de
l'amour et jeux divers me sens pour des
séjours 10 juillet en temps j'ai fait
dans notre rôle est qu'ils ont baissé au
lait nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
i want formi formi formi formidable
kanak c'est lui celui-ci nabeul
[Musique]
tandis que le mans demain
genevois
car rue
issu
là je peux vous faire quelques petites
critiques beaucoup venant de vous
vraiment ça me touche toujours là dans
la mama je vous ai trouvé trop gay et
donc comme ils disent pas assez donc à
la barre
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas une blague c'est un conseil
c'est vrai donc essayé pour mes
prochains concerts hanouna reprend
charles aznavour je crois que ce sera
pas adoubé par charles il a raison
[Musique]